Here, I think it's easiest to complete the square. And it turns out when we
solve to complete the square, we get the answers, negative 5 plus or minus root
22. Great thinking if you got these answers. Keep in mind that you could have
also used the quadratic formula to solve this equation. But since the a here is
one and RB is even, I think it's easiest to complete the square. We subtract 3
from both sides, in order to get x squared plus 10x alone on the left-hand side
of the equation. Now, we can complete our square. We add b over 2 squared to
both sides, which is 25. Now that we've added 25 to both sides, we can rewrite
the left side as the quantity x plus 5 squared. The right hand side just
simplifies to 22. We take the square root of both sides of the equation to get
x plus 5 equals positive or negative root 22. Then, to isolate x, we simply
subtract 5 to get our final answers.